Speaker 1: All right, let's get to a few more
things, it's been a very, very strange 24
hours for the former president, Donald Trump.
While Joe Biden prepares to address the nation
tomorrow about coronavirus and to lay out
a six pronged strategy for how we are going
to get beyond this thing, Donald Trump is
going to be doing pay per view commentary
of some kind for a boxing match.
Former President Donald Trump and also appeared
on Newsmax last night and lied completely
uncontrollably, just totally uncontrollably
about everything.
I want to start with this first clip.
Donald Trump was asked about the California
gubernatorial election, which we will be talking
about in the next segment.
We are going to be covering the results live
next week.
This is an important situation in California.
Donald Trump claimed, of course, without any
evidence that it's probably rigged.
This is happening in the context of Gavin
Newsom starting to pull away in terms of people
saying we want to keep Newsom instead of recall
him in the polling.
We'll get to that polling in a moment.
Here is Donald Trump just spreading lies?
It wasn't a joke when we said they will just
start claiming any election they lose was
rigged.
That's exactly what Donald Trump is doing
here.
Take a look at this.
Got the recall
Speaker 3: election coming up in less than
a week.
It's actually happening as we speak.
The polls appear to show Newsom looks safer
at this point.
Speaker 1: Larry Elder is the man that could
take it from him.
What do you
Speaker 4: think happens in California?
Well, it's probably rigged.
They're sending out all ballots.
All the ballots are, you know, mail out mail
in ballots.
In fact, I guess you even have a case where
you can make your own ballot.
When that happens, nobody's going to win except
these Democrats.
So, you know, look, they're very good.
The one thing they're good at is rigging elections.
So I predict it's a rigged election.
Let's see how.
Speaker 1: So what's going on in reality is
simply that Gavin Newsom is pulling away.
It was very, very close about a month ago
in early August.
Basically, split awareness was much lower
about the fact that this was going on at the
time among Californians.
And as we and others.
I mean, I'm not I'm not saying we accomplished
anything, but just as there's been more and
more attention by media about the fact that,
hey, you could see Newsom removed despite
the amazing economy in California and replaced
with a lunatic like Larry Elder, you've started
to see the keep Newsom crowd pull away where
now they are almost plus 10, plus 10.
Now everybody's got a vote in California.
My brother said he was was filling out his
ballot today.
It's got to be postmarked postmarked by.
Actually, I hope that I hope I'm right about.
I think it has to be postmarked by Tuesday.
So hopefully that will happen.
But there is no evidence whatsoever that this
is rigged.
It wasn't a joke when we said this is the
news story.
Any time they lose, they'll say it was rigged.
Mitt Romney, who won in Utah, remember that
confrontation?
I believe it was at National Airport in Washington,
D.C., where a woman came up to him and said,
you didn't really win.
Your win was also rigged.
Any win they don't like, they simply say it
was rigged.
And what's going on, unfortunately, is that
this is the type of stuff that could lead
to what we're worried will happen on September
18th, which is another one of these riots.
I mean, I hope it doesn't go that way.
Trump continuing to lie throughout the interview.
Then he repeated his often cited lie that
he was down there at Ground Zero on 9/11.
We're coming up on the 20th anniversary of
9/11.
And here's Donald Trump revisiting that same
lie
Speaker 3: at that time.
You you offered to help.
Oh, what a mess we had in New York City.
Give us a reflection of
Speaker 4: that period of
Speaker 1: time 20 years later.
Imagine, by the way, asking Trump to reflect
that.
That's that's that alone is funny.
Speaker 4: Well, I was down there right after
the event and I brought a big group of people
down and I helped a lot of other people, helped.
Those first responders are very brave.
And I'm telling you, that's a lie.
Speaker 1: Trump has been telling that lie
a really, really long time.
Back in twenty nineteen, you might remember
Trump commemorated nine 9/11 first responders
by making it all about himself.
He has told this lie many, many times.
Here is Trump in 2019 telling something very
similar, untrue.
Speaker 5: It also provides pensions for those
who are suffering from cancer and other illnesses
stemming from the toxic debris they were exposed
to in the aftermath of the attacks.
Many of those affected were firefighters,
police officers and other first responders.
And I was down there also, but I'm not considering
myself a first responder.
But I was down there.
I spent a lot of time down there with you.
Speaker 1: So there appears to be absolutely
no evidence of that.
Snopes looked into it and he claimed that
he was there doing who knows what, but SNOP
spoke to officials from New York City Fire
Department.
They spoke to the construction demolition
people who were at ground zero for days and
days and days after the 9/11 attacks.
Nobody recalls ever seeing Trump down there.
And Trump has been exaggerating about it for
a very, very long time.
So that's what's going on.
And then even weirder, as if it needs to get
any weirder.
Donald Trump is going to be providing boxing
commentary for driller's Evander Holyfield,
Vitor Belfort fight on the 20th anniversary
of 9/11.
Just like everything is so bizarre, it's weird
enough that Trump as a former president is
doing boxing commentary.
It's kind of even weirder in some strange
way that he's doing it on the 20th anniversary
of 9/11.
Just all of it reeks of bizarre confusion.
And I don't ultimately know what Trump's political
future is, but so far it's all looking very
strange.